ON FRIDAY.
KOSKINEN 12-2 ON THE YEAR, WON
THREE IN A ROW, PHILLIP DANAULT
UP THROUGH CENTRE, BATTLED FOR,
ULTIMATELY PULLED CREATED OFF O
THEE SHIFT IS ABOUT EFFORT.AFTE
AND EDMONTON WITH THE FIRST
POWER
-- VINTAGE
TRICKLES JUST WIDE.
DRAISAITIT
NUGENT-HOPKINS, SPLAYED OUT AND
LOOK AT THE FLEXIBILITY FROM
JONATHAN QUICKELIEVE
IT, SCAMPERING TO1-0 L L THE
CANVASS.
KOPITAR WILL THE LITTLE TRANSIT
PLAY, BACKPASS BY BROWN, AND HE
PICKS UP SPEED AND LOOKS LIKES'
GOGO FROM DUSTIN BROWN
AT 1:4242
CALL.
NONE FORTH  BY McDAVID
IT KEEPS IT ALIVE.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES THIS POWER
PLAY SO EFFECTIVE.
THE CROWD OF 17,000 PLUS WELL
COMES THE MAN THEY CALL DOC ELE
TOP OF THE SHOULDER.
BEAUTIFUL SHOT TO MAKE IT A E-T
QUICK, AND A GREAT EXTENSION AG
JONATHAN QUICK TO GET BACK
ACROSS THERE URGENCY AND
EFFORT STEPPING UP FOR EDMONTON.
>> Jack: NURSE OFF THE SHORT SI
TO THE NET, UNABLE TO CURL IT
INCLUDING  OVER THE
LINE.
KO
ONE-GOAL GAMES. BY
FOEGELE,K, TOO, BEING A
AND HE'S JUST IN THE RIGHT SPOT.
PICKS UP THE REBOUND AND PUTS I
WRIST SHOT, FOUGHT OFF AND4-1 A
THE KINGS HAVE STRUCK TWICE ONT
LEAD FOR
DANAULT, WRIST SHOT OFF THE
CROSS BAR.
THAT'S FIVEOUGH THE
PADS OF MIKKO KOSKINEN, AND L.A.
HAS PUT THIS GAME
MOORE DIDN'T